Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Mirror Layers.
Now we've got a puzzle here
And its the third puzzle that we've come across
And "qbek" over here is Da Da Da Da Daah.
Which isn't actually a letter
That, I believe, that's a number
In morse code those are numbers
And if I'm not mistaken; Da Da Da Da Daah is "1"
So this is supposed to go in the first slot as far as I know
Zero, One.
Dammit ok, I'm completely wrong. I though I knew my morse code.
I mean that one has a "9" on it and that one has a n-
Fucking FUCKING FUCK!
*Screeching* AGH LET ME THROUGH GOD DAMMIT
*Static*
Why did the door open that way AND NOT the way that it was supposed to open!?
So I'm gonna pull up a reference guide for morse code numbers
Cuz I know letters pretty well But I- I don't know numbers
But the numbers go in a specific order so I thought I was right
Oh I had it backwards
OH I had it backwards!
Oh boy(x2)
Oooh oh oh
(Markiplier Gibberish) Eehgi! Yedidididi!
(Very gutteral) Heeeey. Hi Hows it goin
Oh boy.
(Very gutteral again) Hoooooooooooo
Ok I think he's gone
qwbk, dit dit dit dit da. that would be "9". That's nine right?
yeah. NO!
GOD! I got it backwards again!
Dit dit- dit dit dit dit da is "4"
God! I'm such an idiot. It goes from left to right not right to left.
Imma fricken idiot.
Ok so then. That ones definitely "1"
Then this one might not be "6".
What was this one again? f77...
Dit dit da da da is "2"!
God dammit! I'm fuckin - an idiot.
That's no excuse, I should have known that
That's- that's on me
That's on me everybody! That's on me. Ok.
So 21uc is dit dit dit dit da
Which is "5" even
So I put this in "5", boink.
That should be it
Agh, fuckin, oooh hey
Oh oh oh oh oh oh oooh
Oooh I didn't get it, I don't think
(Anxious) Eeeh
AAAGGHH
AAGH!
I'll be right back! I'll be right back. I'll be right back.
That's two, that's definitely two.
*Static*  So I've got 'em all correct.
Why is this not- *Door closes* -OH FUcking god damn it!
Closed the door on my own face and I got scared
(Sounding out morse code) Duh duh daah daah daah is two.
Ooh! OOHH!!
(Screaming Markigibberish) WellDUHhhmuhGOD!
Oohh! I didn't have all the books!
(Exclaiming in joy and realization) Ohhohoho!
Well ain't that just a bag of dicks?
Okay, here I have been, trying to bash my head against the wall being like
(Mark imitating his past, inferior, ignorant, idiotic self) "This ain't working! Why ain't it working?"
It's cuz I didn't have all of the books.
(Amazed at his own stupidity) Well holy shit!
I thought I was being a big dumb dumdum,
And here I was working on a puzzle with some missing pieces.
Well, ain't that just ass!
"tvs5..." Boink!
(Similarly sounding to a bleating goat) Ooooooh
I thought I had everything.
(Trying to sound out "5iei" like a buffoon) Five EYEYEEAYE
Which has "Cthulu" on it, I was wondering when Cthulu was gonna show up.
I knew I had it right, I knew it was being a bag of douches one me!!
Sure you did mark
There! "yccy!"
So, these are the three that I did not have.
And that should be everything that we don't have
So I just need to put these in.
'Kay, so, "tvs5."
*Beeping Morse Code*
(Sounding out Morse Code) duhduhduh daah daah
(Under his breath) "tvs5"
*Beeping Morse Code*
Alright, got that one!
(Singing) Five EYEYEEAYE
Da da da da It's all das
(quickly) yccy
(In tune to the beeps) Da da da da
Ok so, now we've got the
da da da da as 1
and the da da da da da as 0
dit dit dit dah as 3
dit dit dah dah dah as 2
So we've got everything that we need I just need to take it over one at a time
This is one so this is- it goes over in the one pile (static in background)
One column and it should still be in, yeah
BAH!
That goes in one.
Ok, Badda bing badda boom badda boom boom
ok, Let me back, LET ME BACK
(Markiplier screeching) HE'S GONNA GET ME
HE's (Static) God, nevermind
So next up, is (In same way as before) Five EYEYEEAYE
Which was (Static) ah, fuck, goddammit
That fucking thing.. 5iei
Which is zero
This goes all the way up there
There's a number on the side for that
6, ok
(walking noises) ayayayayah
And then we got tus5, which is dit dit dit dah dah
dit dit dit dah dah, which would be three
Aaah, is that a three, (more enthusiasm) THAT'S A THREE
It's a wonderful THREE
HEY I GOT IT (Good Job Mark) WHO'DA THUNK IT
What the hell is this?
(Silence as Mark figures stuff out)
Hey, I'll blind you over there, I'll blind the monster... maybe (thanks, Mark)
Ok.... well that didn't help
Ok, so... but we do have..
We do have more numbers: 0, 6
Lemme put them in order that they are in: 0, 6
Ok... 0, 6, 11
(mumbles) No, that doesn't pause the game, I'm in trouble
Ok, 0, 6, 21, 30
Unless, it's backwards, it might be.. it might be... backwards
30... but this would make sense, yee
I'LL BLIND YA, I'M BLINDING YA
I'M BLINDING YA (I don't think that's working, Mark)
GET BLINDED, oh that doesn't seem to be working (I wonder why)
(Trademark Markiplier noises) WHOUOOOAYEYAY
I'M GONNA BLIND YA
Something about laser pointers and mirrors, probably
Get lazered
Get face lazered. That's not working, ok, alright then
Get lazer faced, I dunno
Ayyy
(Extreme concentration)
Ok, but I have a LAZER POINTER
Maybe, if I, ah, maybe if I put this in the statue (A+ Idea, Mark)
If I put this in the statue, will it output it
It might do that (Science says no)
HEEEEEE
DA
Oh, shit (Great job, Mark)
Did that...
What happened to it?
Hello? (I don't think a laser can talk)
Did it... It didn't say transfered to MY WORLD
WHAT ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
It better be, it better be in my goddamn folder
(OUTRAGED MARKIPLIER ACTIVATED) NO?! WHAT DID I JUST LOSE IT? NO!
Oh, ok, there it is, ok so that didn't work (You think?) Holy shit, I thought I lost that.
I NEED THIS THING MAYBE
(Insert more markiplier noises) OPBEUBEUBEUE (static)
Ok, so it's gotta be something over here
The level didn't change...
All the mirrors seem to be tinted red, now though, that is a thing
(Even more markiplier noises) SCHBEUBUONBU
Ok, so, I guess the only difference is this map is here, 3 seconds...
Oh, OOH, THAT'S A THING
(Reads symbols out loud) /@*******
So, 7 numbers
7 numbers are there, so that might correlate to the 7 numbers on the sides of these books.
So, /@ Number, Number, Period, Number Number, I just know that guy's gonna come out
Frick
/@ period, comma, period, comma
Ok, I think I can remember that
(Repeats numbers to himself)
(Static while Mark rolls his eyes)
Ok, I think I got it! I think I know what it is. That's not right.
Ok, so it's /@61.10,99.4,64 was it? Did it say 64, I can't remember what it said.
Ah, F- I might not have gotta that but it's /@##.##,##.#, ... 6z!
Woah, woah, woah, hey, THAT'S QUICK
6z, huh? 6 zed, not 64, 6 zed I almost had it
K, Alright, BAIIII
Gonna type this into the COMPUTERRRR
Ok, so, the code is /@61.10.99.4 er comma whatever you guys know
/@61.10,99.4,6z dammit
/@ (repeats) Maybe, hang on, it might be coordinates
It is a mapable (is that a word) coordinate but where is that
and why is it 6z, it's literally in the middle of nowhere, it's in the middle of, Russia (You sound hopeful, there Mark)
Ohhhh, so it's a random location in the middle of Russia
Okaay, so it's nothing!1!! It's literally nothing!1!
OH IT'S ON THE MAP
Oh shit, that doesn't help, goddammit that doesn't help me
Normal map please
Ok, but it's in Russia. Just straight above Mongolia
And If I'm assuming this correctly it gave me a laser pointer to point at it
For 6 seconds, 3 seconds, if I'm not mistaken, which I might be mistaken
So where are you, you are right there
(Holds for the appropriate time length in silence)
No?
(THE MAP BURNS) OOOOH YAY! OHH, YES, YESSSS (I'M SO PROUD)
Woah.
(Reads) I miss mom smiling to you, I miss us. It lied.
OHHH
EEEEE, Oh ok, OH, OOHH NO, OOOHHH NO
(repeats) oh no, oh no, oh no
What have we got here? You want it?
Hello?! I'll play you some tunes
(SPOOKED MARKIPLIER) FUCKING FUCK
I DIDN'T MEAN TO DO THAT! (reads) It made layers of memories.
OHH NO.
Oh my god, but now it's over.
OOH my god, these layers are shattered
These mirror layers. (nods at camera)
I get it, I see it.
Oh! Hello. Oh! Are we back? Is everything the same?
Oh god, it's dark over it. Why does this go nowhere now? Oh, it goes over her, no, oh geez here we go.
Ok. Alright then.Ooook.
Oh. EHH.
OOH!! That was the room to where the statue was.
(clapping) Oh, that was so good! Oh my god, that was so good.
Everything about that was awesome, I can't believe this came out of a game jam.
But then again, a lot of great ideas do come out of game jams and that's why game jams are very important.
Because this is a phenomenal game and this was a phenomenal experience, the puzzle combined with the threat of the enemy
And, and, and it was just short enough like in reality, it was just short enough that the enemy became like- stayed a
kind of a threat the whole time, even though it was easy to get by him, but he could still surprise you because you didn't know when he was coming out
And just also the influence that maybe, maybe that enemy was you in the reflection of the mirror, or was that another room
Or were you looking it someone, were you thinking that you had a brother or something, or twin? I dunno. There's a lot of interpretations that can come out of that
Considering that you miss mom and then father's a bastard and then
And then, I don't know, there's a lot of things to go off about this, but the thing to remember is now this game has gotten such recognition
that the developer is going to make a more refined version for it on steam, and release it fully. Which I highly encourage them to do.
This is a great idea, it's a great concept to have other people involved in solving puzzles, and also
not holding their hand making people rely on others is a very cool way to go about things and I really appreciate that. That's legitimately cool.
And I love that. So, thank you everybody so much for watching. And thank you everybody that participated in this experience, I hope you had a great time, I definitely did.
So thanks again, and as always I will see you In the next video, BUH-BYE